[Music]
all right we are live on the youtube and
joining me today is a youtuber a
fearless defender of free speech and
someone people have very strong opinions
about it even says that in her twitter
bio blaire white welcome to the reuben
report thank you for having me
i can't believe we have not done this in
part we have never met in person before
no and we've tried like a million times
even not even just the show but just
like to hang out we've tried we've tried
for dinners we've tried for coffee we've
tried other times to make this happen in
person all right well then there's a lot
of pressure on us yeah yeah for sure it
has to be good are you feeling the
pressure
i'm fine i feel that pressure doesn't
really affect you it doesn't
you know i watch your videos you like
it's just you strike me as someone
that's clear in your thinking and you
don't care what people think i know
that's sort of a cliche thing to say
about people but you really strike me as
that yeah i mean kind of just the way
i've always been is you know i care
about how my immediate family thinks how
my boyfriend thinks but when it comes to
youtube i feel like you have to have
that thick skin so i've kind of just
always had that yeah been ready for it
all right so for people who know nothing
about you now we did do this once on
skype and i don't want to just repeat
everything that we did for an hour but i
think telling a little bit of your
backstory is good and then we can get to
the to the stuff that you really like
talking about uh so for the people that
just have no idea who you are or know
nothing about your background who is
blaire white
blaire white is a youtuber
um i do social and political commentary
and um i guess i'm known for some
inflammatory videos you know covering
controversial topics that kind of a
thing
but at the end of the day i'm just
having fun with it you know what i mean
just living and i'm doing different kind
of content lately i'm doing more
lifestyle stuff more vlogs more stuff
about me because you know youtube's kind
of changing how it is right now it's
kind of all the rules is there's some
stuff going on on youtube could that be
absolutely absolutely it's getting
harder and harder to do social and
political commentary for sure i mean you
know you know the struggle i mean my
channel luckily hasn't been hit as hard
as a lot of other people that i'm
friends with you
you know whatever youtubers i'm friends
with but uh
i'm feeling the pinch too it's hard yeah
it's kind of weird too we were just
saying before we started it's like your
titles of your videos i mean you do what
you want to do you title things the way
you want to title them the thumbnails
that you put up or the way you want to
do it
i try to play i think a little more by
the traditional youtube rules but
clearly there doesn't seem to be a no an
answer there that's what's crazy is
you're playing by the rules and you're
getting like in trouble for it and i'm
kind of breaking them and i'm fine yeah
but you know knock on wood
by the way i should mention on the wide
shot you might
be able to see
emma is in studio today this is our
first ever live shoot with emma in
studio emma you gonna say hi yeah emma's
in studio uh she was sitting here right
before we started and you were like oh
is the dog gonna stay yeah i said keeper
and then you said keeper so emma's
emma's hanging if she starts uh really
she's saying hi she's saying hi all
right but let's not get too distracted
all right so i don't want to only talk
about trans issues obviously and i'm
sure at some level you've got to be
tired of talking about them in certain
ways um not really not completely i mean
it's still interesting stuff i mean
there's still
so much of it is still a huge debate and
so much of the science is still you know
not out so it's like it's
i guess it gets a little old sometimes
but i'm the mood for it today all right
all right then let's do it so let's just
do a couple of minutes on just your own
uh journey okay uh when did you realize
that you were trans
well i realized i was different when i
was very young when i was probably in
kindergarten or so um didn't really
relate to you know boys in my class
didn't really relate to the girls either
but i didn't really have the language to
describe what that meant until i was
probably a little older maybe 15 16
and even then i went through a huge
denial phase and where i didn't do
anything about it but i wanted to
i wasn't until about age 20 when i
had the means just within myself as an
adult to kind of you know take my life
into my own hands and make the changes i
wanted yeah so i read an interesting
thing this morning when i was doing some
research on you that when you were
realizing this around 1516
your father passed away from cancer when
you were 18 and that actually delayed
your transition
because you didn't want your mom to have
to deal with with losing two people in
her life so yeah
that's fascinating i mean that's deep
that's deep yeah
yeah my dad passed away when i was 19 of
cancer was very very unexpected um and
when someone passes away especially you
know an immediate family member it kind
of halts your life regardless no matter
what you're doing so of course you know
my transition was definitely you know
put on the back burner because i didn't
really want to put my mom through um
losing her husband and then all of a
sudden like oh by the way
uh you're gonna lose your son too and
you know she didn't lose me but it was
just a huge change and when someone dies
it's already a huge change so i kind of
took that into account yeah did you did
your mom know that you were at least
identifying a trans at that point like
was it just the idea that you were
trying to not
talk to her about at that point or was
it actually the transition you know what
i mean like that you didn't want her to
it was the physical change that was
going to be the the real loss here i
guess it was the physical change it was
i mean a lot goes into it it's like a
name change it's like a pronoun change
it's everything so it's kind of like you
know
the identity is kind of shifting um so
it was kind of everything i just didn't
want her to have to deal with it it was
just so much already she was going
through yeah so as someone that's gone
through the transition and we're going
to talk a little bit about some of the
surgeries that you've had recently and i
watched your videos and you were talking
about some of the the
pain and the experience of going through
this stuff that you couldn't have
imagined had you not done it
what do you make of how much we talk
about trans issues now like you know
when there's this whole lgbtq thing and
we did the gay rights thing for a couple
years and gay people got equality uh
which is the whole point we're supposed
to have equal opportunity okay that
we've sort of shifted the discussion now
to trans people do you view that as as
good bad and different
um it's a double-sided word because i
feel like when i look back
you know on the existence of trans
people maybe just in the last past
decade certain things have gotten better
but certain things have gotten worse
more people are more involved in the
conversation and so
there's a lot of unnecessary stuff
flying around and so it's almost like it
was easier and people didn't really know
about it because i mean i think everyone
always knew like oh there are some
people who you know
change their bodies or whatever
but now that everyone's so involved in
the debate
there's just so much back and forth
that's unnecessary like like the
bathroom thing that's unnecessary to be
for the most part you know meaning what
so what's your take on the bathroom
thing well it's just like
it's not real life like i i don't like
being expected to like suspend my
knowledge of how the real world works to
have these debates because because i've
never had an issue using any bathroom i
wanted i just never have um
so it's like it's about understanding
people's concerns but also being like
okay it's not a real concern or it's not
that bad you know it's just it's so much
unnecessary stuff do you think maybe for
you that's a little bit unique in the
trans community because of the way you
look you know what i mean so i know
people talk about someone that's
passable or or you're beautiful in this
case so it's like nobody's
nobody's looking at you i think or or
maybe the most keen eye who's thinking
about this all the time you know video
but i don't think so i don't think
anyone's looking at you and thinks thank
you yeah so that in this way you don't
have to think about that specific
problem so much because you are more it
is passable the right word i guess so i
know you don't care about words that
much in that regard i guess it's the
right word yeah uh
i suppose it is i suppose that if i was
six feet tall or whatever it wouldn't be
as easy you know what i mean
but at the same time you know a lot of
people talk about rapes in the bathrooms
and mall stations in the bathrooms and
it's just it's just not a thing there's
no
facts to back it up there's no
statistics to back it up so that part i
get annoyed with that's really the only
part though yeah it's one of those
things that when we had that whole
brouhaha about what happened it was like
well trans people have been going to the
bathroom of their choice for all this
time and there didn't seem to be an
issue so now we've got
the left in this case screaming about an
issue that didn't exist and then you do
have some create an issue so now we
you've created an issue where for me as
a small government guy well now you want
the government to come in and tell you
know cut funding for places that don't
do this and that with the bathroom and
all that but there is a genuine
group of other people and in this case
they're more on the right maybe maybe a
conservative christian right or whatever
that is that do have some issue with
trans people right absolutely and you
know what i'm incredibly as long as they
are not putting their hands on me or
cruel i'm absolutely sympathetic to that
because i have those people in my family
yeah uh my mom started the family was
definitely more on the liberal side and
they've been very very accepting my
dad's side it's been something different
it you know a lot of people on my dad's
side of the family
are more on the conservative side which
is fine you know i lean right as well
but
when it comes to the trans thing they
just they didn't get it especially at
first yeah um and so for me it was about
learning to be patient with those people
which is why i feel like that kind of
bleeds over to my online presence is
with those people you know i'm able to
interact with them and it's like it's
fine you know yeah i love that because
that's what it's all about right like
you took people who knew you as as one
thing now know you as something else and
even if they struggled with it or even
if you probably have some people that
still struggle with it in your family
right at some level maybe absolutely
there's still um turmoil on that end
it's not crazy or extreme or anything
you know it's not something i think
about every day but it's still there um
and so you know i think that a lot of
the times when it comes to trans people
they sort of have the wrong
mindset when it comes to family i mean i
can't judge every situation but
i feel like if you want someone to be
patient and understand you and come to
learn about you and your thoughts and
your beliefs and who you are you have to
do the same it's a two-way street so a
lot of trans people get caught up in
like being very very defensive and like
if you don't accept me on every single
term then you can't be in my life which
is sad because family is everything you
know you can't throw people away and i
used to see that you know before i was
doing this in what seems like another
life for me i i was on the lgbt channel
on siriusxm i wanted to do politics but
i was gay so they're like you'll do a
gay show gay guy yeah i was on that and
i would come across or i'd interview a
lot of times that type of person who you
know gay people didn't have equal rights
i obviously wanted gay people to have
equal rights but that type of person who
was so strident in removing all of these
people from their lives making it seem
that they're all bigots and all that
stuff and it's like
that's not how you change minds and
that's the kind of advice a lot of the
advocates have they act gay advocates as
well um and it's very toxic because
family is everything you can't just
throw people away
you have to it's meaning in the middle
you know do you see that as a uh
interesting paradox of all this that i
agree with you i think family and
friends are far more important than what
larger society is going to say about you
certainly what the government is going
to say about you you know again you want
the equal rights but there's like a
certain strange thing there where
they're trying to almost replace the
family
with some of the the social justice
stuff like that should be your new
family because they know everything
about you the way they think you should
be absolutely and i've talked about this
on my channel how when i was younger
like 15 16 17 i was very heavily
involved in social justice circles and
everything and there definitely is this
aspect of like this is your new group
this is your new tribe um and it's
definitely you know
if your mom can't accept you then you
don't have a mom there anymore you know
what i mean and it's very very toxic and
it's like the worst thing to tell to
someone when they're when they're
needing support beyond the superficial
support of like political activists like
that that only goes so deep you know
right right so
um
it's wrong yeah tell me a little more
about that so in that time of your life
you're
starting to have these realizations or i
guess you had them very young but they
were becoming more
concrete i suppose and you were really
in that sjw thing i read something about
how you had a list of words on your
refrigerator that was it that you
couldn't say or that people who came to
your house couldn't say i didn't make it
but i had a roommate that i was totally
fine with it but it was like a
white board on the refrigerator a list
of words you couldn't say in the house
and it was like stupid stuff it was like
terms like men's rights or it
i don't even remember it was just all
the things you would guess right um so
that was my life for a while and uh
were you again when you were in it at
that time did you you so you really did
feel it like you felt it was right i
felt it it it felt like finding like a
new uh purpose almost
because at that time like i said that
was when the realization that i was
trans was really hitting hard and so at
that point you know you feel you feel
powerless you're at the beginning you're
like how do i make this work you know
how do i live my life in the way that i
want
and you meet a group of people who tell
you that you know every problem you have
isn't your problem but it's everyone
else's problem
and then that's very uh intoxicating to
hear at that stage if you're that
confused or lost or whatever yeah so
it's almost like they prey on weaklings
a lot
they bring on the smaller groups the
disenfranchised groups and they
suck them up and become a bigger
group right which in your case is
particularly interesting because now
with someone that has the views that you
have and we'll get to some of those
political views and as you said you lean
slight right um
they're not a huge fan of yours now
no i have dealt with
so much from my youtube channel all day
like stuff i don't even talk about yeah
so much stuff um
last summer uh there was a huge run-in
with black lives matter
and
a lot of the activists there obviously
saw my videos on black lives matter and
i was docs my address was posted um
people were tweeting me about coming to
my house with guns um all kinds of stuff
which you know
it's crazy and it's online but when it
comes to that you have to take it
seriously so i was i talked with the fbi
and a girl got arrested and my fans i
don't endorse it i do not endorse it but
my fans swatted the black lives matter
activists like sent you know that's when
you send a
i guess police to someone's house and
say they're going to kill themselves or
something and they come up with guns so
you know it's been really crazy and i've
lost a lot of friends over it um but it
is worth it youtube has changed my life
uh i'm here i would have never been here
you know what i mean so it's all worth
it but there's been so much just so much
yeah does it blow your mind how much of
that online world thing this you know
the doxing the swatting the fighting how
much of that i think in the last couple
years especially has sort of leaked into
real life where suddenly now you know if
someone knows what your address is they
can find or just any of that stuff that
that attitude has now leaked into
reality
yeah and it's a crazy attitude i mean a
lot of the stuff at the end of the day i
mean i see on twitter sometimes people
getting doxxed you know you ever see
like viral tweets just going and
someone's getting docs because they said
the n-word or something and it's like
okay when you do that you're not only
affecting that person and putting them
at risk but it's like they might have
kids a wife a mother anyone in their
household you know what i mean so it's
crazy it's like the most insane thing
you can do to someone yeah we've sort of
lost civility right i think one of the
things
one of the things i'm going to try to do
this next year i think i try to do it in
general is bring some civility back to
some of this because we need it you know
you might not believe me but i'm trying
that too i really am no well yeah i know
you are actually because you've been
having debates on your channel and you
go pretty deep with some people that you
obviously disagree with some people that
you've been in public fights with and
stuff like that and you're doing it in a
way that i think is civil
yeah and um the way i do
all my channel and stuff is lately is i
try to do debates and especially
just on the daily i mostly only watch
political content that i disagree with
honestly i don't really turn on you know
fellow youtubers do the same thing as me
or you know news channels that kind of
mirror my views or whatever it's all
other stuff that's more interesting to
me because you learn more about your own
views and someone else's views and
people don't stay
caricatures
yeah you know people become people and
ideas become
more tangible and something you can
actually argue against rather than just
being incendiary or
whatever which has been kind of my style
in the past but try new things yeah all
right so then as someone who is now
watching stuff that you don't agree with
so now that means you're really watching
a lot of the the diversity stuff
probably the sjw stuff and all that
what's that i watch the views you watch
the view which is crazy
i don't watch it anymore but that year
that one year where elizabeth hasselbeck
and rosie were getting into fights it
was incredible television there and when
elizabeth left i think it basically it
like it took like uh like a hit to the
knee of the show but that i have no
problem with that show for the mo i
haven't watched it lately
it's very very
liberal um they had like an interview
that's why they needed elizabeth right
you needed like the balance you can't
just talk the most conservative person
they have on there now is like a
libertarian and it's like that's fine
but like
when everyone else is super far left you
have to have a balance um but yeah i
like watching it because i wouldn't
worry about myself through that you know
yeah so as someone that is watching some
of that stuff now and is now debating
some of these people what was the moment
for you that that political thing
switched not just the personal part that
was obvious you were going through
things but that moment that the ideas
how they relate to politics and just
sort of a world view it was just
becoming an adult honestly it was
learning to take accountability for
myself and
not rely on an ideology that told me
that i was powerless um it was
yeah it was just growing older which is
crazy when i see like you know 40 year
old you know activists which you know
fight for what you believe in but some
of these people have like the mindsets
of like teenagers it's crazy you know
just trying to push accountability on
other people yeah it's not not the best
way to be did any of your friends that
you were in at that time did they any of
them you know keep you around after that
or do they all just was like just like
that's it some but the ones that stayed
were the more you know
centered people and not like the crazy
activists those all drop me like that
which is fine you know um i look at
where they are all in life and i don't
mind being away from it
you did that very civilly it was a dig
i'm being nicer today it was very civil
that was very impressive um how old were
you when you first started doing the
youtube thing
uh
22. 20. i'm almost 24.
turning 24 in two days jeez well happy
birthday in advance but you're so man
only barely two years that you've been
doing the youtube thing i mean that's
like a life changer right that's a
transition of another sort right going
to the public person thing absolutely
youtube has changed my life opened up so
many doors and never thought would be
opened um i've met so many amazing
people through youtube so i believe in
youtube despite all the crazy things
happening right now like i believe in
youtube i think it's an amazing platform
and i will stick with it i might switch
to other platforms as well not switch
but you know do stuff elsewhere yeah but
youtube will always be at least i hope
uh my bread and butter you know i feel
exactly the same way well said um all
right so let's talk about just some of
the the issues and the stuff that
sometimes gets you in hot water and some
of the things that you as i said at the
beginning i consider you one of the
people that's a fearless defender of
free speech um
so first off so you agree
that trans is a mental disorder correct
yeah more specifically gender dysphoria
is mental disorder i mean that's just
recognized in the dsm um so that's just
signing from the tsm um
just for the for the absolute layman
we'll just do some one-on-one stuff so
gender dysphoria is gender dysphoria is
basically feeling um a strong disconnect
with um your gender and gender roles
that you're expected to fill being that
gender um and it causes a lot of you
know distress and it's it's very
difficult it's like um it's alleviated a
lot for me in the past year or so
but when it was hitting me the hardest
it's so hard to deal with it's like
depression times five it's horrible yeah
um
so it's a mental disorder which is fine
for me to admit because people have
disorder people have anxiety people have
depression people have
uh you know whatever so it's not this
crazy inflammatory thing for me to say
at least i think but a lot of other
people feel differently yeah
do you watch the show uh transparent by
any chance no no i don't so the one of
the interesting things i i just watched
it just in the last couple months and um
without getting into any plot stuff um
one of the most interesting things to me
is that the father is transitioning and
really the story doesn't become about
the father it comes about all the people
around him the family around him and
there's a moment where uh he becomes
friends with a trans woman who basically
is like you're going to lose everyone
around you and that
he hasn't yet in the show i don't know
which way they're going to go with it
but that also must be a part of the
struggle after it sounds like it's been
pretty okay for you but for a lot of
other trans people that just other
people just oh they can't even if they
want to accept they just can't
get there for whatever reason yeah there
are people that can't get there um it's
been
in comparison to a lot of other people
relatively easy for me like i have a
huge family and 98 of them are fine with
it um but but it is it is hard you know
like gender dysphoria itself you have
this like
very toxic view of yourself and it's
very hard to just exist and just go to
the store and just be yourself it's kind
of hard to explain to someone who would
never experience it you know what i mean
but it's um
basically feeling very uncomfortable in
your body like to the extreme
uh so to top that with like familial
like not being accepting it's it's bad
yeah do you think there's a risk or any
issue with lgbtqt
that i think in that like so for me as a
as a gay man i don't have any innate
understanding of what it's like to be
trans that a straight man wouldn't have
oh cause it's like sexuality and then
gender identity right so like just
inherently i don't somehow know
something more about you than if if i
happen to be straighter if there was a
straight guy sitting next to me
do you think that by lumping all these
things together there's some kind of
risk there like i think maybe perhaps i
have a little more empathy
built into me because i
was in the closet and struggled and blah
blah blah we have certain lines of like
you know similarities but it is very
different um
i think in the beginning it was
necessary you know what i mean like when
there was less of an understanding of
what trans was it kind of was treated
like another you know these are the
queer people and this was that was their
tribe yeah and so in the beginning you
know in the 60s during the stonewall
riots perhaps that was
um
beneficial now
um
it is so different and the politics are
different and um the place that trans
people are at and the place that gay
people and bisexual people and lesbians
are at is different
i still don't really know what queer
means
you know what i mean like a lot of words
and a lot of letters yeah i guess that's
just like an umbrella but then it's like
lgbt is already an umbrella acronym i
don't know but
i guess um
i don't think too much about it as far
as like grouping them in and why it
might be bad yeah it's not a big deal
one of the things i've seen you talk
about is uh that you're against having
young kids transition as early as seems
to be happening more often there was
just a story this week about what like a
14 year old
boy who transitioned who now
wants to detransition or whatever
whatever the exact phrase is yeah um and
you've been very outspoken about that
absolutely that's one of the uh
i don't consider myself some sort of
like warrior fighter but if there's a
fight in my channel or what i'm talking
about that's one of the things that i
consider one of the biggest fights
because
there really are no other trans people
speaking out against it at least that
are like you know in the public eye or
whatever
so i'm definitely against children
transitioning i think that it's a
horrible
decision to let a child make a
life-changing decision and decide to be
sterile because that is a consequence of
transitioning so young you can't have
kids
and just the drugs that they go on
there's a lot of problematic things that
go along with that um there's a show
called i am jazz it's on i think tlc or
something
and um it's about a 16 year old trans
girl
and she had been transitioning since she
was probably like
five not medically medically around like
11 or 12. so she's put on puberty
blockers which is what you go on before
hormones it basically she never went
through testosterone or male puberty
and because of that um
it's kind of gnarly but her genitals
like never really developed and so she
can't even have the surgery to like
become
you know a woman and have a vagina
because she was on puberty blockers and
puberty blockers are hailed as like the
most important thing to go on yeah wait
can you explain that a little further
because i think that i think that goes
over a lot of people say it's like she
actually needs to undergo the proper
surgery
at the end so to speak she actually
needs fully formed japanese right um
male genitals yeah it's so gnarly and
it's like really graphic but the amount
of depth that you can have in the vagina
is directly related to how long the
penis is so if you are on purity
blockers from the time you're 11 years
old you never develop you basically have
a micro penis and you can never turn it
into a vagina it's just too small so
it's like there's problems and
the trans
activists for lack of buyer terms
completely gloss over it and make it
seem like something that's not and i
don't like that so i fight against that
for sure yeah i i know of the show but i
i haven't been watching it are they
addressing that as an issue like yeah
they're going to like consultations on
the show and all these surgeons are
saying oh we can't do it and there's
only so many surgeons that can do it
there's like just like maybe a dozen in
the us who even do that so it's like
what do you need to do now yeah it's so
interesting because it strikes me as
something that's so consistent with the
way you think of other things like just
because they're saying it just because
they're all saying oh let these kids on
it doesn't mean that even the facts if
you want to get to the end to truly
transition the facts don't line up with
what's making you feel good yes let kids
do whatever they want and okay all that
stuff but the actual medical reasons to
not do it
from the amount that i understand that
you're explaining to me far would
supersede what your feelings are about
absolutely another huge problem is um
the activists always cite that you know
so many doctors are fine with it and
it's like okay but
trans education in medical school is
actually very very new like very new
like it's it wasn't even required up
until very recently for people to even
learn about trans people and transition
in medical school
one of the things that trans people
often find it's hard to even find like a
proper endocrinologist which is a
hormone specialist to even do the
transition so it's like you're citing
all these medical professionals when
half the medical world doesn't really
know what it's doing people are just
basically running into the dark with
this and that's what's scary because
kids lives are online you know and i've
never been the person who's like a child
advocate fighting for the kids kids are
our future but
you know i mean that story alone that
you talked about was on my twitter the
other day um the kid went on hormones at
12.
decided at 14 it was a mistake and it's
like
cool like that kid just missed out on
two years of development who knows
what's going to happen because of that
yeah so it's like playing with people's
lives so in a case like that so you have
a 12 year old that is identifying as
trans what you would then want is for
them to deal do all the psychological
work you would want them to be fully
accepted by their family and friends and
all those things but basically just wait
on any uh hormones or anything like that
until
is it when puberty's done or do you
think it should be 18 like is there a
number associated with that for you
where you think okay well now is the
moment or is that individual well that's
what's difficult as well i mean
bare minimum 18 for me i wouldn't really
go higher than that i think when you're
18 you're an adult and you know
for better or worse you kind of have the
ability to mess up your life
if that's the case or make it amazingly
better you know my life i don't ever i
don't ever want to frame transition it's
like something that's like completely
negative like it's opened my life up
entirely i would never yeah i don't
think you do that at all yeah yeah uh
but it is something that's also very
serious and it changes the entire course
of your life so the idea that you know
kids are making that decision is i think
very problematic yeah so there's an
interesting money piece around this and
you've talked a little bit about um that
you don't want the government paying for
people's transitioning first right yeah
yeah yeah for sure i mean i think that's
something i mean
at the end of the day it is to alleviate
gender dysphoria which is a disorder but
it's all cosmetic in a way too you know
what i mean like i just had surgery i'm
only like a month and a few days out of
surgery and um you know
everyone's story is different but i
worked hard to save up for it and i paid
for it myself and um
didn't go through any like insurance or
government or a sugar daddy or anything
like that so this was fully paid for
yeah and i wanted to do it that way
because i felt like i don't want to you
know live my life and look back and like
remember someone else splitting the bill
you know what i mean it's my thing it's
my life um and it just feels better that
way but again that's me yeah so this is
interesting then so as someone that
again you lean right so i don't know
what your feelings are on universal
healthcare per se but if we're
identifying gender dysphoria as a
disorder if someone was to have gender
dysphoria how could a health insurance
company not have to pay for it i'm going
a little insider baseball here with you
yeah i mean that's i mean that's
completely true i think it's about um
first of all we have to learn how to
actually diagnose gender dysphoria
properly because so many people get
diagnosed
i don't really have it like they just
don't so that needs to be the first
thing
and then meaning what then what what do
they have they just have they're just
struggling with their sexuality or other
identity issues yeah a lot of the times
um
another interesting piece of this is
that trauma like emotional trauma
psychological trauma or physical when
you're younger if you're someone who
went through a rape or was beaten can
sometimes manifest that way
i read a story the other day of a kid
who
was raised by a really abusive mother
and the mother used to one of the ways
that she would abuse him when she would
call him by a female name and making
more dresses and stuff and as he got
older
he had gender dysphoria what he thought
was gender dysphoria because
he didn't really know how to identify
with his gender because his abusive
mother was like confusing the hell out
of him
um and he went and he transitioned and
he did everything like every surgery you
could do
hormones everything and at the end was
like oh wow this isn't this isn't me i'm
not comfortable
so
there's a lot of
gray areas with this that i feel like
people just don't
pay attention to yeah which again is why
it's scary that kids are on the line for
this yeah well it just goes to how
poorly we are about debating really
complex issues and i would put this at
sort of
this deals with so much at sort of an
existential level and a biological level
and everything else this should be
something that really we should be
debating from the most educated place
and i think we do a horrible job of that
we do a horrible job before i don't even
do the best job it's hard you know
there's like i said there's so many gray
areas and
um there's so many like for instance uh
there is the american college of
pediatrics i believe it's called a lot
of people cite them as
a good source they're not like they're
not actually pediatricians they just
have the name
and a lot of people cite like a lot of
really anti-trans stuff from them wow
and it's not a real source and people
really go hard with that so it's like
there's just so much it's just a mess
yeah
that's why i said i think it's almost
better like people didn't really know
what it was because there was a few
doctors that could do it and it's like
if you needed it you know 0.1 percent of
the population it's fine but now it's
like everyone's involved everyone has an
opinion and just makes it harder yeah
it's such a symptom of what's going on
in a bigger way in society of just
everyone having an opinion about
everything now i know we're all for the
free speech things so these people
should be allowed to say whatever they
want of course and encourage but just
this this endless opinion machine on
things that people don't know about i
think a great example of that is when
trump made this proclamation about the
the trans ban and you were the first
person i quickly jumped on twitter all
right who can i try to make some sense
of this thing from
what was your basic take on it um i
think you and i had a similar opinion at
first i don't know if you changed yours
i kind of shifted mine but initially i
was like why you know i mean like it
doesn't make sense but why pick the
fight yeah why pick the fight why is it
important um i think there's like
a very small amount of trans people in
the army there's never really been an
issue um but it also took me like i'm
just some prissy training from
california you know what i mean like i
don't know about
how the military works it took me kind
of looking at like oh wow there's
actually like basically if you stub your
toe the wrong way you can't join the
military so of course if you have like
gender dysphoria it's something that's
like that debilitating like maybe you
shouldn't be at least on the front lines
for me i felt like um banning trans
people from every
you know position in the military was
kind of little
overkill but um i can understand the
front lines thing for sure yeah did you
change your opinion at all what do you
think well i tried to
i tried and you know you sometimes fail
on twitter but i tried to tweet out a
few different thoughts that i was having
because i wasn't feeling like i fully
understand this and uh sort of what
you're saying it's like i'm not in the
military also so for me to pretend that
i know everything about protocol and
what it's like to be on the battlefield
or in a uh you know in a housing unit
with a bunch of soldiers and all of
those things so i tried to look at what
some military people were saying people
like you a few other people that i
generally respect i mean my feeling is
that if you have transitioned so first
off there's the argument about the money
right so i don't think the government
should i don't think the military should
have to pay for your transition that's
just what i feel that's my more
libertarian side coming out but that's
okay so all right so we got one there
the other part though is that if you
have passed every psychological test
if you've transitioned and now you've
passed every psychological test that
they would apply to everyone else well i
do believe in equal opportunity so at
that point
i would argue it's probably irrelevant
whether it's combat or anything else
but i also tweeted a list of things that
there was a guy who's a military guy did
you see that who tweeted out like a
20-string tweet
about the pressures of being on the
battlefield on the battlefield and he
was making it clear that he's not
against trans people in any way he was
just saying if there's an extra element
of psychological uh issues there that it
could complicate things i just thought
it was an interesting take and then of
course i got a lot of hate for even
sharing it yeah i saw that yeah i said
just read this with an open mind that's
all i was really saying so but yes the
point is that it goes to one of those
things where it's like
man this is complicated as [ __ ]
it is it is um one of the main concerns
i had with the whole situation was just
um
finding out and making sure that the
trans people who already were in the
military didn't lose any like va
benefits afterwards because that's
that's really crappy to like serve your
life and then leave and it's just like
you're dishonorably discharged and uh no
benefits that that's crappy to me but um
i'm not losing sleep over like
not being able to be drafted now so
that's great you know what i mean like
i'm cool with that right
there you go that's pretty good guys by
the way we are gonna do uh patreon and
super chat questions uh after about an
hour uh with blair we're gonna jump in
let you guys do that so uh you can put
questions on patreon and on super chat
right now um let's talk a little bit
let's move away some from trans stuff
have we have we done it sure for now you
think did you miss anything you feel
like we got it okay okay good um some of
the other political stuff so you
describe yourself as leaning right and
you obviously have a libertarian piece
of you what else does that mean if you
say i lean right
right well you know i hold some leftist
views as well you know what i mean like
i think you and i both agree on the
traditional you know free speech i think
that's still defined as like a leftist
thing
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
i was i was really i was saying the
other day you know maybe like we aren't
all moving right maybe everything's just
moving left i think that's actually the
case um right that everything else is
moving left or side or that left hand so
far we're all kind of yeah the world has
moved left you haven't moved right maybe
that's the case um but
when it comes to fiscal responsibility
when it comes to national security when
it comes to you know just a lot of
things and
so i definitely say a lean right but i
also don't fight for any team you know
what i mean i'm not um
rooting for any team i speak for myself
i analyze each issue and situation and
come out with what i think does that put
you in an interesting position because
it kind of opens you up from hate for
everybody
like uh you know i'll see people be like
ruben's a secret republican conservative
blah blah blah and i'm like if that if
that's true or he's far right he's all
right all this crazy [ __ ] it's like if
that's true well then i guess those guys
are okay with gay marriage they're okay
with someone who's pro-choice they're
someone who's pro-legalization of
marijuana who doesn't want a nation
build for euthanasia i mean a good you
know four strong public education blah
blah blah yeah
yeah it definitely does because
first of all you can never please
everyone um and we live in such a such a
divisive time and look at tommy lahren
like she took one step outside of you
know
her team with the uh what was that the
abortion comments on the view and she
lost everything she's doing good now
which is great yeah but uh she lost
everything so we live in a time where
people are all playing by the book and
fighting for teams which really has
never been my style which is fine
because i'm on youtube and it's
independent it's fine you know what i
mean i don't have anyone who's going to
fire me right
again yeah
keep things yeah you want a piece of
wood that we could just put maybe yeah
just ready for you that way that would
be better you could just keep it in your
pocket all right i'm just constantly
doing that i you know i actually don't
know your feelings on abortion did you
agree with the premise of what tommy was
saying
um
i go so back and forth on abortion there
there is a small part of me that's like
oh my god i'm trans and i have to deal
with that i almost don't want to talk
about it but i do you know obviously
have views on it um i will not accept
that as an answer yeah i know i know i
know i'm definitely
pro-life with the exception just as a
general rule pro-life with the exception
of incessant rape kind of the basic
thing you know what i mean i think that
if you don't have to have an abortion
you shouldn't but at the same time it's
not libertarian to me i'm not trying to
tell someone what they should do with
their bodies just for me a moral
decision would be if i could get
pregnant would be that i would be
pro-life unless i got raped or had an
inset situation yeah it's one of those
things that's so complicated and that's
why when i see these idiots screaming at
each other it's like no one hates women
and no one hates babies it's like one is
trying to protect
life in in that sense and one is trying
to protect the woman so for someone like
you that has that libertarian vent
though if you were gonna uh
and we're totally just spitballing this
obviously we didn't discuss any of this
stuff that we were gonna talk yeah we're
fine um
that if you were as a pro-life person
what would you do then if a woman let's
say a 16 year old girl gets pregnant
it's an accident whatever she has no
support or anything do you think the
government has any role if the
government's not going to allow her
to
have an abortion do you think the
government has any role then
in helping that child helping her etc
i'd say so if we're gonna keep it
illegal then there needs to be some type
of recourse i mean you can't just have
dumpster babies i mean it sounds so
horrible but that's kind of the reality
of what happens is like if someone can't
take care of a baby you literally cannot
and has no family those kids end up in
dumpsters those kids end up dying those
kids end up you know with malnutrition
so that is a thing yeah for sure yeah i
mean i'm with you on that basically like
yes in most cases i would like either
their community or their church or
mosque or whatever it is to help take
care of them but this is one of the
places where i think if the government's
going to say no you can't do this
then in some way the government is sort
of responsible so it's one of those
places where all of us have these sort
of political ideas and yet the rubber
meets the road and then you got to kind
of figure out what you really believe
and i'm such a like
individualist that whenever i hear a
question like what do you think would
worship and i automatically put it back
to myself what i would do so obviously
what i would do is you know
not have an abortion but uh it's a wide
world out there a lot of different
situations so i'd agree there should be
recourse if it's illegal yeah i like the
that you just said the phrase
individualist because i think you know i
mentioned the lgbtq thing before that
because i'm i'm a little older than you
uh that when even though i was closeted
for a long time and i never really felt
that i was part of the gay community
whatever that is i never i always liked
basketball i never i'm a horrible dancer
like i just never really felt in it like
that
yeah you like basketball oh no no i mean
they may never fit in oh okay lgbt are
you a good dancer
uh kind of i dance basically like cosby
which these days is particularly weird
it used to be like kind of corny and fun
now i dance like the greatest serial
raper of all time it's like okay we have
to go out on one of these
for sure
for sure yeah yeah um
but the the idea that the lgbt community
whatever you want to call that has lost
some of the individualism is actually
very sad to me that i used to live in
west hollywood which is basically the
gayest place on earth there are rainbow
crosswalks truly i mean it is the gayest
place and that the community has sort of
succumbed to groupthink even when when
gay people weren't treated equally there
was a very cool rebel streak i think
milo actually makes this point really
well there was like this sort of
subversive like cool yeah and i think
they've tr traded it i suppose for
equality which is of course which is
great important under the law but it's
that it loses a little
bit do you see that too even with the
trans community community i hate the
word community too i know but i mean it
is a community really i mean even if i'm
not a part of it as a community i've
never felt a part of it i've always i
mean there's
i've always felt there's a lot of
problems particularly i can't really
speak to the gay community i've had a
lot of gay friends but i've never been
like super involved in that
sector but when it comes to trans people
there's so many problems with with that
community um
so much sex work
so much
disconnect from family no family values
in that community really um and so
that's always been a problem for me i've
never really been able to relate to
other trans people every once in a blue
moon i meet one that's like
down to earth and normal and fine not
that i'm like the most normal person
but um i've never felt at home in that
community or the lgbt community i've
been to a million gay and trans and
lesbian functions
always like the black sheep not not in a
negative way like all these people are
bad or whatever but it's just never been
my tribe yeah i mean we should do some
sort of like we should do like a get
together for like the black sheep lgbt
years that's a that's a party that i
could actually probably have fun at
probably probably it's it's always been
kind of a thing for me and for a long
time i was like upset by it like that i
couldn't relate to them and i feel like
something's wrong with me but then i
look at the state
and it sounds like i'm like just trash
talking the trans community but i guess
i kind of am um i look at the state of
where that community is and it's like
why would i want to fit in with that i
mean
i don't have anything against sex work
per se but it's very depressing to be
around a bunch of people who feel like
the only thing they can do in life is
sex work
um that's like their only course of
action because the truth is it really
isn't i mean there's issues and there's
a severe unemployment problem in the
trans community but
we're not at this place of like trans
people can only have sex for money
and i just don't like being around that
honestly yeah i sound like an uptight
christian but geez but i don't cross
lady i don't it's just not fun to be
around honestly just a different
lifestyle all right let's take a big
loop uh big jump big jump islam you talk
about islam
that makes a certain amount of people
not like you yeah when i've watched your
videos on islam i think you do a pretty
good job of making a distinction between
a set of ideas and a group of people and
that we shouldn't be prejudiced towards
people but we're allowed to criticize
ideas you have to that doesn't get
through to a lot of people though no it
doesn't it doesn't um so
obviously as a trans person i have a
huge problem with islam i would have a
huge problem living in any islamic
country
um is there one you could openly the way
you would want to live that you know of
there's about 40 or so
i don't think being trans because um
even uh
dubai like that's supposed to be like
the the liberal haven of the muslim
world and even there there's not a lot
of problems um there's a youtuber named
gigi gorgeous who like was stopped at
the airport couldn't even enter the
country it was like detained so it's
like well you can't go to dubai like
where can you go certainly not saudi
arabia wasn't there even a straight a
heterosexual couple
that was kissing on the beach in dubai
and got arrested yeah so it's not quite
yeah it's okay there are other problems
too yeah clearly yeah clearly for the
liberal haven yeah clearly so um but
even more so than like religion i i
focus on culture and i would never want
that culture to become something that's
super prominent here because that
wouldn't be in my best interest you know
what i mean or anyone's best interest
women's best interests men's best
interests a lot of people a lot of
people talk about women in the muslim
world as as you know as victims which
they are you know i get a lot of
just insane messages from women and lgbt
people in the middle east but i also get
a lot from men who feel like um they're
trapped as well everyone's in a very
strict um role there yeah so um it would
be in no one's best interest for that to
be here yeah so what makes the left go
so defensive on islam and so offensive
on christianity because they're brown
they think they're brown they think they
think there are plenty of white muslims
there's plenty of
absolutely so that's a huge
misconception on the left where i think
they fight so hard because which is why
they call you know people who
voice concerns about islam racist
because they associate that with brown
people and um
apparently if you're brown
you have to have all these you know
20 year old white saviors jumping to
your
your rescue if you could only have more
purple haired girls at colleges
defending you then everything would be
okay right right it's because they're
brown honestly it's it's really that
simple i think which then as i've said
many times is the actual definition of
prejudice
because you're pre-judging people based
on their color absolutely because you
think of uh
you know
when it comes to christianity like the
slightest problems with christianity
which there are some but not really that
many anymore um they'll jump on that
like the like the the the gay cake
situations all the time that pop up
sometimes you know that'll be like the
end of the world yeah where were you on
the gay cake thing by the way just as a
sideway um i didn't care i didn't care
it was the stupidest thing in the world
whenever that pops up it's like but what
i didn't like is that um these small
shop owners just get their lives ruined
over it and it's just like media
attention to the extreme and like their
shops get shut down and they lose their
livelihoods that's horrible
um
but
another one of those like petty disputes
i just i can't care about that too much
you know yeah i'm guessing you were
probably basically with me on that which
be would be that i don't want the
government telling a private company
absolutely to offer a specific service i
wouldn't demand that the government tell
a jewish painter to be forced to paint
holocaust uh imagery if someone
commissioned them to do it so it's sort
of absolutely it's a sucky thing it kind
of sucks like field doesn't feel right
but yeah it doesn't feel right it's not
to say that that's like the kind of the
christian thing to do to turn someone
away but um
what people don't talk about is a lot of
these activists go to places like that
they go to christian bakeries because
they want to start something they want
the media attention they want to
they want something to fight for
um so that's messed up yeah
all right so here's what we're gonna do
guys we are gonna take questions with
blair in about five minutes again we're
doing it on super chat we're doing it on
patreon there are roughly four jillion
of them already can you do all four
jillian i can do all four or four
jillian that's a lot all right but but
so uh sort of one last thing that i want
to make sure we get to in case we don't
get it to questions so you did just as
you said just about a month ago you
underwent several other surgeries which
you were very open about there's a video
on your channel where you're were you
holding the camera in that one yeah i
was so you're holding the camera and you
know you've got the bandages all over
and you're talking about so can you just
describe a couple of the things that
that you underwent sure i'll describe
all of them yeah i got my breasts done
so i got my breasts done um i got uh
my forehead basically reconstructed
um biological males have a ridge on
their forehead they also have a higher
hairline and just more space in between
the eyebrows and the eyeball so i got
all that changed my eyebrows lifted my
brow bone shaved my hairline lowered and
i also got a rhinoplasty um so just
those three things and from there like
i'm done with my transition which is
like an amazing feeling to have it done
at 23.
uh
it was probably
not even probably it was the most
intense thing i've ever been through
the most pain i have 40 staples that
went all along my head like to the back
of my ears
nose job was fine nose job didn't hurt
that much the breast hurt a lot felt
like an elephant sat on my chest
um so i'm just glad to be mostly healed
i'm still a little swollen honestly i
was probably advised to like not get
back to like being on camera yet but i
had to i had to yeah i mean it's
incredible to me after watching that
video and i was looking at it going wait
a minute wait a minute this is only a
month ago and then i knew you were going
to be here today and i've you know seen
pictures of you since then and all that
i was like holy cow i mean the human
body is actually an amazing thing it can
feel absolutely i mean i was literally
like sliced open like the way they do it
do you want to get really graphic
the way they do it is so they
make an incision all along like i said
to the back of your ears they peel your
face down and then they
like it's almost like medieval feeling
they saw the bone down
so i was like leatherface how afraid
were you either that something could
could actually go wrong which i'm sure
does happen sometimes or that you know
you could look at now you're in la i
mean you're going to walk around and see
all these women all the time and plenty
of men now too actually with you know
plastic surgery gone wrong that are
having far less done than what you just
did how worried were you when you just
when you finally took that last gasp of
the gas or whatever when they put you
under um i wasn't worried honestly
because uh
like i'm not dumb and like i did my
research and i made sure who i was going
to was a great doctor
um
so i had faith in him but of course you
go through like the the freak out like
the night before like i vlogged and i
was like crying i was like so scared
because it was my first surgery but it
was also something that was really
important to me so i got through it and
um it improved my life exponentially
exponentially like i feel
just so much better about myself and
like everything's just kind of i can
breathe it's great yeah it's incredible
i mean it's it's really it's like the
aura of what you're talking about it's
coming through for sure so you said
those are the last surgeries now you did
not have bottom surgery correct yeah and
and what's your reasoning on that um
there's a lot of reasons why i
haven't gotten undone if i could have
like a
fully functioning like perfect vagina
out the womb great i would do that but
when it comes to that surgery it's so
much money it's tens of thousands of
dollars it's a lot of risk like it's a
very risky surgery um
it's the best it's ever been it's risky
in terms of actual life or is it just in
terms of not like death but like
complications you know what i mean like
you can lose the ability to orgasm which
i mean
that's like that's like really important
in life it's origami you're down with
the orgasms
um
and also the recovery time is extreme
it's like a year of recovery and it's
really intense recovery it's like the
worst like way worse than what i did um
and i don't have the down time to be
like just like in my room for a year
healing like it's just it's it's not for
me so i'm comfortable with how i am now
and i'm just done
yeah all right uh
i think we're going to move on to some
audience questions oh god how'd i do i
think i did all right you did great
you did great too do you want to even
pause or should we oh you know we are
going to pause for 30 seconds i'm going
to refill your water all right guys one
more time questions on patreon questions
on super chat so load them up right now
give us one minute for a little water
and check on the dog and we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys we're back with blair
white how's your leg it's good it was so
dead before we paused it was like
it's horrible all right we had you get
up we did a little stretching okay we're
good to go all right there's a zillion
things here so let's just jump right in
uh from patreon how difficult has the
trans community community been with her
given many of her views that run counter
to the general position they hold we
talked about this a little bit but have
you gotten like any particularly like
really hateful stuff from trans people
because you talk about the things that
you do absolutely um if you just search
up like blair white trans on youtube i
feel like there's a million videos from
trans people who are just like trashing
me which is fine um a ton of threats ton
of like if you show up at this event
we're going to do this it's crazy but
a lot of the um trans activists that
aren't actually trans are just activists
who fight for trans people because
that's like their fight yeah um they're
the worst though they're the worst
that's interesting because uh
uh brett weinstein at evergreen state
was telling me that sort of same thing
he never feared violence from any of the
black students but he feared violence
from the white students because they
were the ones that had to really prove
how pro black or whatever that they
really were which is really kind of kind
of fascinating um super chat dave your
beard is looking good hashtag no shave
dave okay thank you uh
do you have a all right i think it's
staying do you have a favorite
subscriber and would you ever consider
doing a collab video with them
favorite subscriber a favorite
subscriber
i think someone's trying to hint
something to you right
probably just all my patreon supporters
because obviously they go the hardest
you know and they're the greatest um
that would be cool to do a video like
with all the patreon supporters yeah how
important is the patreon thing to i
don't even mean just financially but
just the fact that people are like
i'm voluntarily doing this like if if
half of them dropped you'd probably
still figure out a way to make videos
you know yeah and yet they're
voluntarily saying take this and
hopefully these ideas get out there i
think it's incredible absolutely
i love them i mean the fact that another
person would say this content and this
person is worth this even if it's a
dollar you know it's it's very
flattering
absolutely uh all right patreon what is
your opinion on special rights and
benefits for specific groups of people
for example minorities have affirmative
affirmative action married people get a
financial benefit people with kids get
tax breaks etc
uh well i'm looking forward to the tax
breaks i want to get married so let's
maybe keep that um affirmative action i
feel like um there was a time and place
for that which is now gone
especially for women um
and then as far as like if we can relate
it to like the trans thing a lot of the
activists fight for um special
employment rights like not being able to
use the wrong pronoun in the workplace
which actually makes the trans person
who's being employed a huge liability
because then like who wants to hire
someone who's like a financial it's
already bad enough for the trans
community as far as unemployment and
they make it worse so
are you pretty much in lockstep with
jordan peterson on the on the pronoun
stuff like right there he's not against
tran i've never heard him say one
anti-person thing just don't tell me
what i have to say and certainly don't
make it a law absolutely he's tweeted me
and been very kind to me he's not a
hater of trans people he just doesn't
want to be told what to say which is
like the bare minimum in life like tell
me what to say
right uh super chat are gay traps also
straight
oh my god that's like
can you explain that mathematical yeah
it's really really good
are our gay traps still straight what's
the question
what do they mean by traps so this is
like a newer phrase okay so trap is like
it's like 4chan lingo it's where it
originated i believe it's like boys who
dressed up as girls and don't tell the
person they're sleeping with they're not
trans they're like traps they're just
like you've probably seen the type
around hollywood like they're not trans
they're not making changes like that but
they're just like they're trapping
people which is like super immoral and
just like horrible um so
traps are gay
because they're trying because they're
just gay boys like dressing up with
girls and tricking guys right thoughts
are good makes sense to me
i'm a simple man super chat combat vet
here i have seen warren can say with
confidence that it is not the place for
a group with a forty percent lifetime
suicide rate why create even more
suicidal vets thanks for your candor and
honesty that that's an interesting way
of looking at it that there are so many
vets already with suicide problems i
don't know that i probably link that
together right i mean i don't think
there's any data to see if that like
compounds or something or if it's like
put together you know what i mean but um
again i much prefer to hear from people
like that
than to sit here as like
like i said a prissy [ __ ] from
california talking about like oh
military's like i just i take that with
more than a grain of salt for sure
yeah that's interesting uh you know you
say the word [ __ ] and i know that a
certain amount of people are
you know freaking probably while
watching this but you're just trying to
own the word right i mean i don't or
even anything i don't even know that
you're even i think it's a cute word i
think it's a funny word i i don't mind
it
fair enough
um we touch on this a little bit but
maybe you have like a an anticodor
saying what does your family think of
your videos so we talk about the way
your family thinks of you so yeah that's
it that's a good question my videos um
they don't talk about it much
like i said my family's big and most of
them are very liberal so it's probably
just a topic they don't want to talk
about
but one thing you learn about when you
start youtube where you start doing
videos or public stuff is that everyone
you know and you've ever known watches
like everyone you know what i mean
you kind of don't expect that but
everyone watches it um i've never had
any like negative backlash from my
actually no that's a lie i had a cousin
who blocked me on facebook like two
months ago this she was saying um she
doesn't want anyone to think she's a fan
of me because she hates my videos or
something i was like oh that's so mean
wow but um other than that it's been
fine in a way there's something kind of
good about that because it's like she
probably was okay with you being trans
she doesn't like your political ideas
so although that sucks and i talk about
why that's wrong all the time blocking
people over that but there's something
kind of funny in that it's like i'm okay
with you as a human can't take your
political views whatever uh
super chat long live freedom of speech
okay i think we both agree on that um
this is good because we touch on this
right at the end uh from super chat what
kind of psychological benefits does the
appearance change and surgeries have on
you and are there any detriments how did
you decide you were stable enough so you
made it pretty clear like that you
really feel like yourself now you feel
good about what just happened and all
that yeah um but are were there any
detrimental side effects to that or
anything um like afterwards like
changing how you look was there
detrimental side yeah i think yeah like
any level of regret or anything
no um i was hit pretty hard with like a
post-surgery depression which is very
normal no matter what you're getting
done
um so there was like a few days where i
was like oh my god what did i do like
this is so painful i don't know if i'm
gonna like how it looks at the end but
um it's completely changed my life now
in only positive ways like i feel more
confident like i'm okay with like the
camera hitting me from whatever angle
because i know that like i'm fine now on
my face so um you have no idea how many
angles we're working with i know you
guys are getting better
but it's been great
yeah
um we did touch on this one a little bit
before but i don't know if we got an
exact number what do you think is the
minimum appropriate age to talk to kids
about gender dysphoria are parents
justified in sheltering their kids from
these topics uh-huh i think they're
completely justified i'm
when i have kids i'm definitely not
going to be talking about all this stuff
with them until they're very old um
obviously the trans thing is going to
come up because they'll be able to
google me or whatever um but i don't see
any reason why
anything beyond teaching kids to be kind
to people regardless of who they're
interacting with i don't see why you
should go past that i think when they
get a little older and you know they hit
puberty and start learning that you know
the boys in their class sometimes are
going for the other boys or whatever and
then it's like appropriate but when it's
like little kids just don't confuse them
i'm curious have you ever been
approached by any of the lgbt
organizations or glaad or human rights
watcher or any of those so
so i want people to really understand
that because i was always ignored by all
them when i was doing my thing too
because i was even though i wasn't fully
where i am now and you want me to
believe i wasn't there yeah and i was
always ignored by them and i'm ignored
by them now which i don't even care
about but i but i think people should
really understand that that you because
you're an individual who thinks what you
think
they will never this group from this
sort of umbrella group that controls a
lot of the gay fun out there you'll
never see me at an hrc red carpet at a
glad red carpet never
um
you know i don't mind it even even with
youtube like i see youtube promoting um
trans youtubers who
thought about size but are much smaller
like a thousand subscribers um
simply because they're maintaining the
narrative they want them to maintain the
videos aren't even that great
um
and again not that my videos are amazing
but uh no but you but your videos are
great and
your audience loves thank you huge
numbers and all that so thank you that
does show you how this diversity memo
that we've all been talking about with
this james damore thing at google a lot
how that has seeped into all of these
companies why why can't youtube promote
one of your videos if they're doing
something about trans people right and i
guess i can understand certain videos
like you don't have to promote the ones
where it's like you know me with blood
on my face talking about how trainings
get beat up for tricking men or
something you know i mean like not that
one but like normal ones like my
transition video why not everyone else
does it that's trans but i'm not losing
sleep over it i'm doing my own thing
yeah all right guys reminder we are
taking questions on super chat right
here on youtube we're also taking
questions on patreon uh and here we go
uh do you feel that having so many
different labels in the transgender
community helps or hinders the idea of
gender diversity for example does it
open the doors to free sexuality or does
it create more barriers what do they
mean by so many different labels in the
transgender community are there are
there labels that i may be missing
within the community itself i think so
because they they do like the non-binary
thing and like the agender thing and
there's just a lot of different terms
floating around um and it creates
barriers for sure i mean that's just
kind of how the human mind works we
categorize people and we find our tribe
and to start splitting the tribe even
smaller it's like then it's just a bunch
of people who are in their own little
bubbles you know it does create
division it doesn't bring people
together do you think it also just
causes exhaustion i talked a little bit
about this with lacy green that when you
get something to the point where you
have to label every little person's
feelings about every little thing
so much that i think of the average
person is just like [ __ ] this like i
don't need to i'm not even going to talk
about this right what's the point right
like you and i's audience like we're
very involved in all these conversations
but when it comes to real people like
you can't just walk to 7-eleven and
start talking about non-binary and [ __ ]
like it doesn't compute it's not real
life that goes back to me saying i don't
appreciate being like expected to
suspend my belief of how the real world
works so it's like it's almost tiring
talking about it that being said you are
pretty upset about the amount amount of
non-binary cashiers at 7-eleven these
days right right there's just so many
it's just so many it's getting out of
hand it really it's just sickening uh
super chat hi blair what are your
thoughts regarding passing as it relates
to politics around trans issues also
apparently jazz is getting surgery i
read so is that news to you well good
for her if she found a surgeon i just
know that there was like a struggle
which is crazy um what that's
interesting the passing as it relates to
politics i guess the way you could
relate that is that caitlyn jenner
because
she obviously had great surgeons and you
know some people it's probably just a
little more uh digestion
yeah digestible but i didn't want it so
that their features at the beginning may
be a little more easy to transition with
or whatever it is that if she had come
out on the other side looking very
different or not passing that perhaps
she wouldn't have been as accepted as
she was
probably yeah i mean i mean that's
another way that human mind works like
we like to look at people and especially
when it comes to gender we like to look
at people and like know what they are um
because identifying gender is
subconscious you look at someone you
don't think um it's not like a thought
is that a man or a woman it's like you
see features and your mind automatically
it triggers and you know what they are
automatically so it is more digestible
to have someone who just you know what
they are or even if you know they're
trans
they look enough towards like they're
normal looking you know what i mean so
it is hard um and not everyone has
access to surgeries or whatever um
so
you can be aware that it helps but uh i
don't think it's like that detrimental
either yeah i don't know i'm throwing in
a bonus one for me because it's not here
when it comes to just the general hate
and just okay so these people go after
you and yes a certain amount of people
are going to go after you now because
you're popular and all of those things
you know i know a lot of people say oh i
don't care about any of that i don't
read any of that but i really sent
something and you like i really sense
that you don't care at all
i don't care because again it's not
real life it's like i have my boyfriend
back in the green room i have my mom i
can go cough i need to talk to her i
have my family i have a roof over my
head what why would i care why would i
care you know as long as you're not
putting your hands on me or like being
crazy in public which has really not
happened that much to me a few times uh
then i'm fine yeah i think we all need a
little more of that in our lives
probably probably me included um
regarding puberty blockers this is from
patreon regarding puberty blockers and
or hormone treatment for children
consent becomes an issue don't you think
it makes more sense to wait until they
have better executive functions relevant
for consent as measured by objective
criteria such as prefrontal cortex
development rate which would be white
gray matter of ratio of change similar
to those we already consider capable of
consent this would be about 14 to 16
years old on average if i remember well
so i like the fact that that was kind of
technical but basically saying that
there's a you need their own brains to
be developed enough yeah yeah i mean
just think back to yourself for 12 you
think you really could have made a
decision that impacts the rest of your
life you just can't i think of myself at
35 i was an idiot right
right so you get to 35 sister you have
no idea
24.
um but yeah i totally agree that they
can't even properly consent they can't
consent to sex legally they can't
consent to drinking they can't consent
to driving
you really make consent just changing
their sex it's crazy
it's a really interesting thing um are
there any other trans youtubers who
think the way you do that's interesting
because there's definitely plenty that
go after you i see enough about that
are there some that are on the on the
blair train
um yeah one of the most interesting
things about my channel is that i've
i don't want to sound conceited but
because of my channel there's been other
trans people that have come out and like
been like blair's the reason why i feel
like i can say this that ain't conceited
that's just
okay that's just honest um so that's
been really great for me just to see
every once in a while a video will pop
up from a trans person saying so
i've thought this all my life but i
didn't want to say it but i saw blair
talking about it and now i can and i
think that's great you know what i mean
i think um the more freedom to say what
you want um the better for sure
so there's a few not a lot though
obviously
i'm the minority in this community so
yeah and there but there are there for
sure i mentioned that i had been uh at
uh my brother-in-law's farm in seattle
and it's sort of a communal farm and he
lives with a trans girl who was a gun
uh advocate and she was painting her she
was painting her um gun locker pink
while we were there and she you know
hunts and does all kinds of other stuff
and it was during that whole thing about
the the army and that was oh and that
was one of the things i tweeted that day
which was like i would much rather have
this girl defending me than me she knows
a lot more about guns and could probably
live off the grid a lot longer than i
could so it's like what right would i
have it's kind of like a misconception
um people think transgenderism is
political it's really not it's
definitely outside the political realm
people just politicize it you know what
i mean so that's why i've always said
you could be like a gun-toting training
alabama or a green-haired feminist
[ __ ] in san francisco there is a lot
of um intellectual diversity not as much
as there should be because a lot of
people do feel pressured to align more
with the green-haired san francisco
training but right um it's almost like
we shouldn't judge as individuals and
not as collectives almost like that boy
it really makes you think all right guys
we are still on uh on patreon and super
chat here we go
uh for both of you which community has
been the most hostile least accepting of
you as a bi-libertarian man my christian
conservative friends have been very
accepting the gay community the least
you want me to feel that one first sure
so i find lately especially i'm finding
that the christian
conservative christian community has
been absurdly open i think they've sort
of gotten not to say there aren't some
people using uh scripture in a bigoted
way but even when i was on vacation i
met these christian conservatives that
could not have cared less and they
wanted to know if i was a good person
and all that i think right now for all
the things that i believe in i get more
flack act well i get way more from just
the so-called tolerant left
then on the right people don't i get
invited to all these i'm speaking
tonight at a libertarian thing at uh at
a college outside of la and it's like
claremont mckenna and it's like
these are supposedly scary right-wingers
they're going to be your enemies yeah
and they're inviting the gay married
pro-choice pro-weed guy to come talk to
them so who is intolerant what about for
you absolutely i'm i completely relate
to that um i didn't expect to be that
way though it took me making my youtube
channel um to kind of understand that
like
it is kind of a new thing but it's there
that people care more about ideas than
people you know what i mean or than
identities uh so
a lot of my hate almost 98 of my hate
comes from people who fight for trans
rights which is so crazy to me yeah god
that's nuts i mean i would say 98
probably that's probably the right
number for me it's like i never get hate
mail from people on the right gay
marriage ah pro i just don't they go we
disagree with you or i've had people
sitting in this very chair in my own
home who told me they weren't for gay
marriage but i was okay with the
conversation yeah yeah real life
conversations are always so different
too they're better there you go uh
would you be interested in talking to
ben shapiro about transgenderism i would
love to i actually was doing a live
stream a week ago and um i was saying
how i would love to do a video with ben
shapiro just talking about it um not
necessarily a heated debate or whatever
but um just going over it'd be so
interesting because we have similar
views but also radically different views
when it comes to it you know what why
don't i talk to ben and we'll see if we
can do it right here hook me up i think
you know you know he ben's a good guy
and even if you guys won't make peace on
that specific thing i think there's a
lot more that you agree with and i know
that for sure you'd use that as a
jumping off point all right do you think
that gender dysphoria is something that
one is born with or do you think it's a
product and or rejection of one's
environment
i think it can be both um
i i think back in my life and i remember
being four or five years old feeling it
so to me that feels like well maybe i
really was born with something you know
different in my brain and that's why i
had it happening
but like i said there is events like
trauma that can cause what feels like
gender dysphoria or even gender
dysphoria um
so it can be both for sure
uh all right super chat we've got we got
about 12 minutes left guys if you want
to jump in on super chat or on patreon
uh with lasik eye surgery not being
covered by most health insurance
companies it's rated the same as plastic
surgery why is trans being pushed when
there are others that benefit physical
health
that's that's an interesting question
i mean i couldn't say i guess um when it
comes to being trans there's like the
suicide aspect and when it comes to just
having bad eyesight it's just having bad
eyesight i want lasik by the way i have
horrible eyes all right i knew you
weren't done with your surgeries i am
legally blind people don't know that i'm
legally blind i have contacts in right
now but without them i wouldn't be able
to see you really yeah
it's very passable yeah
thanks very passable um
oh this is really interesting uh from
patreon thoughts on tsa body scanners as
it relates to trans men and women oh i
have so much to say yeah yeah okay
so i've been flying a lot this summer um
i have a boyfriend out here so i've been
going back and forth from where i live
to la where he lives and um
every single time i have ever flown in
my life since being trans since
transitioning um i've been
the scanner pops up my body and i have
to get patted down every single time
i've never not had that happen um and it
definitely is like super invasive and
it's like
because what happens is when you go up
to tsa the agent has to select male or
female so when i'm walking through they
select female but then on the scanner
an anomaly pops up in the crotch area
which is you know what i mean right uh
so every time i have to call it an
anomaly
an anomaly
um so it's invasive it's really
frustrating i understand that tsa is
there to keep everyone safe but
uh it's like the worst thing in the
world because sometimes they're like
rude about it and you're treated like
you're a terrorist yeah and it's like
come on
yeah i'm walking in like sections i'm a
terrorist right i mean everyone hates
tsa so much yeah and so much of it is
such the theater of the absurd that
adding this into it i can only imagine
last time it was the worst last time i
flew they took me to the back and
everything and they were like asking me
questions i was like are you kidding me
i literally would just tell him i have a
penis yeah i'm just telling them i have
a penis and so it's frustrating but
sort of is what it is i suppose uh
patreon even if sex is genetically
defined don't you think it makes more
sense for sexual orientation to be based
on a pattern of attraction based on what
triggers it that is since we have no
gene scanning vision the secondary
sexual characteristics of a person an
overall masculinity femininity
femininity instead of sex
something there might have went over my
head did you the same that's kind of a
confusing question yeah all right you
know what if you can reword that one
maybe maybe i just read it in a strange
way um okay let's jump back to super
chat um
blair how do you approach dating as a
trans woman did you have to come out as
trans after beginning a relationship do
you have any advice for other trans
women
um advice would be just to be honest
from the jump like before you even jump
before when you're walking towards the
job be honest um because you don't want
to put yourself in position where you
can be hurt um you don't want to put the
other person in a position where they're
uncomfortable um always just be honest
uh for me
never had a problem dating i've never
had a problem finding people who are
okay with it um not that i've dated many
people i've had three relationships in
my life they've always they've all been
serious too um
but dating
i've always met people through the
internet and so a lot of times we'll
just google blair white and it's like
it is what it is yeah um but just be
honest always yeah sure in i mean i
don't know we can only go as personal as
you want to go but i just met your
boyfriend seems like a great guy um does
it bring up issues
for the person that you're with
family and yeah as far as family right
like that
he seems like a great guy and obviously
you guys are great together but that
yeah then he almost the onus is suddenly
on him to have to explain something to
family and friends that he never had to
explain before like it just compounds
like a series of issues yeah it gets
complicated um i've had good luck even
with that like dating like families have
always been great um the cool thing
about his family is that they're
actually like fans of me and they knew
about me before
that's the case so that's been like
pretty cool but that's also a unique
position for me it's not the same for
everyone obviously um but i mean his
family's great and they they like me so
so the main point of advice there is
always date someone whose family is a
fan of you
right right start a youtube channel
start a youtube channel and get to it um
i've seen a couple things about gender
neutral pronouns
anything specific on that that you want
to hit on people can want to be called
what they want i don't use them though
really yeah it's awkward um oh oh i
think you're gonna dig this one from
super chat would you consider converting
to islam just to watch the progressives
rise from the conflicting tears that you
occupy on the social victim slash enemy
scale that'd be the biggest f ever
anywhere like that's crazy uh no lindsay
lohan's a muslim now do you know that i
heard about it she's a muslim now
it's crazy i miss mean girls lindsay do
you know that uh i've told the story a
couple times but for about a year i had
lindsey lohan's ipod i can't quite
explain why i had it and how it got into
my possession i don't want to explain it
right now i'll tell you later that's so
crazy because they would involve i could
get someone in trouble
a lot of britney spears ton of britney
spears i knew it this was about i don't
know it was probably about eight years
ago so like whatever britney's peak was
it was right around then that's crazy a
lot of britney spears but i had lindsay
lohan's ipod uh should assault rifles be
banned
um i'm not for banning things no i'm not
for banning things fair enough um
uh you sort of addressed this already
but maybe we can whittle it down a
little bit from patreon regarding
military service do you believe that
people that are transitioning should be
allowed on the front line so i think
it's there's a couple questions here so
i think your answer was no right
my answer was i can understand the
argument
i'm kind of with you that if someone
passes all the tests why not but at the
same time i'm me i'm not involved in the
military right it's hard it's
interesting the way the person wrote
this because they said that are
transitioning so they didn't say finish
transitioning um then then probably not
that's probably even just like to their
own benefit not the best
right because there could be physical
reasons yeah they're still going through
things okay uh and then it continues my
concern is that a frontline scenario and
their potential reliance on hormone
replacement therapy that in a wartime
scenario they may not have access to
those medications and risk becoming a
danger in terms of trans suicide rates
which turn risks on their fellow
soldiers and their altered mental state
at the loss of h uh to the hormone
replacement therapy that's interesting
that just in the cause of war adding an
extra element where you need certain
yeah if you're relying on a medication
like that then yeah
then i would say no right i mean if you
were on the front lines and you needed
diabetes medication yeah that also that
doesn't work
yeah yeah but then again there's also so
many great areas because not all trans
people are on hormones it's it's all the
great areas we talked about yeah
it's a lot it's a lot um
i love this one this is from facebook
actually
teach me how not to care about other
people's opinions blair yeah we've hit
this a couple times any other
bonus advice on sure i would say um
stabilize your own life so you're not
reliant on other people's acceptance um
because you can have people mad at you
from every angle but if you're living
your life and you're supporting yourself
and you're fine then who cares yeah um
just just do your own thing it doesn't
matter you can't get caught up in that i
like it uh i think i'm gonna i'm gonna
pre-say yes to this one can the two of
you please have a meet-up in la you're
my two favorite youtubers we should do a
joint meetup that'd be so cool all right
we will do a joint meet up uh
we will discuss the details of that
privately uh
super chat what is your opinion on the
lack of rights libertarian arts and
cultural output
any current authors
the lack of write slash libertarian
output on arts
oh maybe how um
art seems to mostly come from the left
yeah you know what i mean i mean it does
you look at media you look at movies
music all of that um all of it comes
from from the left really that's why
especially being here in hollywood which
is where it all comes from we talked
about how
everyone here is a leftist basically um
yeah i would say especially um the
people on the right should maybe
get more monopoly on that uh
same with um
i just lost my thought
oh with social media how we shouldn't um
the right should make more social media
outlets rather than also always relying
on twitter and stuff silicon valley has
like a stranglehold on all of that so i
think it's important to start
diversifying that for sure yeah it
definitely does are you
enthused though at least how many
libertarians or classical liberals
whatever it is are on youtube because
you see all these these people young
people get on youtube they start earning
money they start realizing what they
want involved in their life or not and i
see so many of them actually shifting to
libertarianism because of that so that's
at least in enthusiasm
rather than just we may not have enough
artists yet yeah when it comes to
youtube actually um libertarians and
right-wing people and republicans
actually have a monopoly on youtube it's
kind of crazy like if you look at um
leftist channels they don't do as well
and they get a lot of dislikes um but
again that's not real life because you
know i can be on youtube and see a lot
of people saying what i would say and
whole views that i hold i walk down the
street in hollywood and it's completely
the opposite so hollywood ain't real
life
okay i think they did reword their their
questions so to reword my previous
question do you think sexual orientation
should be based on secondary sexual
characteristics
and noticeable cues instead of sex which
is something we can't naturally detect
unaided this would make
liking traps or people with the xy
female
uh syndrome not gay i know what they're
saying yeah uh they're basically saying
like um
is sexual orientation defined by
secondary sex characteristics which is
like your face your body outward rather
than just genitals and i would say that
that's actually kind of how it works
like
if you look at um one thing i like to
say when people think that it's like um
homosexual to be with a trans woman it's
like well it's not the straightest thing
not the gayest thing uh but also that if
you
you also it's not the same thing but you
can't say
um because you ask them if you look at
like a trans man do you know who um buck
angel is
i do know about angel i had interviewed
him on my old uh
lgbt thing on siriusxm right so he's a
trans man female to male transsexual and
has a vagina yeah porn star porn star
successful porn star yeah um
i don't think straight men are lining up
to [ __ ] buck angel you know what i mean
can i curse i'm so sorry it's the first
time i curse i i think you want to do it
again okay [ __ ] um
yeah straight men aren't lining up to
[ __ ] because he has a vagina it's
more about secondary sex characteristics
of which she has everything male
secondary right now so i wonder i mean
he probably knows but what who are the
people that are mostly watching that
then i don't even know what do those
people identify as is kind of really
interesting i don't know about trans
men and their porn
that's actually really niche i think but
when it comes to
porn of trans women what i do know is
that
um that porn only exists on straight
websites in the beginning when transport
first started becoming a thing they put
it on gay websites and it didn't do well
they put it on straight websites and it
just boomed that's interesting is that
this is going to sound completely uh
amateur or something but is there trans
porn of
for guys that have fully transitioned or
at that point why would you
you mean like male to female yeah
right fully transition bottom and
everything then at that point what would
be the purpose of watching porn of that
person so that's got to be a very very
niche yeah if they like fully transition
they lose their stardom for sure right
yeah but but where you're at would
actually be there's plenty of porn like
that i mean
there's plenty yeah i wouldn't do it
though i've been offered yeah i'm not
trying to convince you to become a porn
star here that would be that would be
quite a way of doing it uh okay uh we're
gonna do a couple more minutes here
again it's uh we're on patreon we're on
super chat oh and we're doing a we're
doing a rapid fire i don't even tell you
but you're sticking around for a rapid
fire for patrons only where i'm just
gonna plow through things that uh yeah
and you're just gonna have to right
after the porn talk i'm gonna plow yeah
okay and trust me there's a lot of juicy
stuff there um okay a couple people
asked about your modernization situation
you you already said it didn't hit you
that hard and you're sort of surprised
by that actually right yeah i'm
definitely surprised
uh all right we're gonna wrap up uh
do we have one more here that i feel
like i feel i feel good about this you
feel good about this i feel great all
right in that case all right so here's
what we do we are gonna do uh the rapid
fire on patreon we are gonna do some
sort of uh hangout in la and the four of
us are gonna do dinner but that will but
that will involve no count you're okay
with doing something with no cameras
right
yeah i don't need dinner on camera
double date let's do it yeah all right
awesome all right well it's been a
pleasure and uh yes we're doing rapid
fire on patreon thank you guys for
watching and oh and i just this morning
taped an interview with greg gutfeld it
was really really fun uh cool guy and
got an interesting perspective on a guy
that's in mainstream cable news but gets
the online world it was really uh it was
fun to chat with them so check that out
tomorrow and i'm at claremont mckenna if
you happen to be outside of la tonight
all right later
[Music]
you